So krypton is one of the noble gases, it’s
not very reactive but it does
react with the element fluorine. Jim Turner,
who was my supervisor
when I did my doctorate, was the first person
to discover that fluorine
could react with krypton but even that reaction
requires quite bright
lights to break the bond between the fluorine
atoms to get them to
react. But krypton can also be used in lasers
when mixtures of krypton
and of fluorine-containing compound can be
used to generate very bright
pulses or intense pulses of ultraviolet light.
Some years ago we had a
professor here who bought a really big krypton-fluoride
laser and when
he switched it on and the beam hit the wall
it burnt a hole right through
the wall so he knew where to make the hole
to get his beam into the
next lab.